[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody how's it going uh
i didn't i
said i was gonna take this live but i
realized my mic was off and i already
switched over to my camera so we're
starting the stream off great
going everybody
uh hey i'm john luke uh here at gamespot
and i am joined by a couple of
lovely folks uh to be playing the
anacrusis which is the uh
new left 4 dead style game uh by i think
a couple former left 4 dead devs uh
worked on it um it's out in early access
today and it's uh on game pass which is
uh how i'm playing it uh so yeah we're
going to sound off with everyone here
first off i got the one and only ben
janka
heck yeah thanks for joining me ben
always i always love to have you on
uh
then uh we have uh returning for his
second time on our stream uh will uh
crosby you were on our extra live stream
uh how's it going sir
i like shooting things
and i like
heck yeah
um
and finally we have uh phoenix phoenix
how's it going this is your first time
on one of our streams
oh no i'm realizing people can't hear
you guys
oh i did this whole intro and i set up
the thing
man this is going great
wow hold on
i literally tested this like a second
ago what is going on hold on
okay talk for me now guys i'll talk for
you
i know what the issue was okay i figured
it out i'm just stupid apologies um
okay let's just start over here hey
everybody i'm john luke we're playing
the end of cruises i'm joined by ben
jenka say hi ben
it's me
i'm joined by uh will crosby
say hi everyone
and i'm joined by phoenix uh say hello
phoenix uh phoenix i've never actually
asked how do you uh say your last name
oh uh jetpack you just like phonetically
say it as it is
uh okay uh yeah
i i'm terrible at phonetics but i'll
give it a try uh
uh
sarn sarnic
get pissed
right yep there it is wow nailed it i
love her that's a cool that's a cool
last name man
thanks yeah got it for my birthday
all right guys we're gonna check out the
anacrysis um
it is out today in early access let's
just jump into this thing man so i saw
some people on the chat saying that
there has been server issues and in fact
i think here on
uh the news ticker it says they are
having server issues um but we're in a
full party already so hopefully that
means we don't have to worry about any
of that and we can just play the game
yeah
worst case we'll write it out together
we'll figure it out
yeah it'll be fine it'll be fine
all right i'm gonna switch over my
monitor here so i can see better um all
right let's just get into it uh i have
not played
any of this yet
uh i shot like three aliens and then i
cool oh
okay so we all got the same error right
yes
oh and it booted us too oh no
i was in a blast
oh no
oh no guys
so guys is the stream dead in the water
are we not even gonna get to do it i'm
gonna i'm gonna back out i'm gonna look
at my thing and i'm gonna see if there's
an update okay all right we're gonna
take this for the time this time oh
i was so excited i was like we're gonna
have enough lovely thursday we're gonna
play this game
no
everything is bob jones things breaking
yes everything's breaking this stream is
going wonderfully
[Music]
i do like this menu music it's quite
ethereal yeah it's quite nice it's quite
nice
pretty pretty
maxing pretty pretty nice
it didn't prompt for an update
maybe we're good
how do i rejoin you
um you should just be able to join me um
by finding my name and joining i can
send you guys an invite in a sec i just
need to
uh
switch over so the audience doesn't see
my friends list if that's the case um
no it's okay windows game bar just needs
to get its act together oh dude don't
even get me started i'll win bar
the party menu wouldn't let me join you
but the friends menu would let me join
you
wild
one game
i also wonder so
okay no party settings
there's no
like i can't pick like um
any sort of
now like specific network options
it's weird that we're able to join a
party but then we just can't
start the game up at all
maybe that was just like a weird a weird
small thing
maybe but it's the exact issue that one
person in the chat was saying so i'm a
little uh
this is why you don't live stream on on
launch day
i mean
we have to launch on
we have to live stream on launch day
because it's our job
to check out the new games
this is why you don't do it
because this happens
okay so we're all here should we try
here let's try again let's let's see
episode one oh guys first try here we go
come on
starting game
loading up
[Music]
okay i'm gonna see out of curiosity i'm
gonna see if i can just play by myself
if that works
wow no it does not
it does not work
oh shoot
okay i'm taking it to the twitter
i'm going i'm going to see what what
they've been saying
dear twitter
a new gameplay trailer hot off the
presses i remember
well what other games does everyone have
installed
trinidad hernandez says we should just
play spelunky uh too
oh yeah that's on game pass it's true
it's freshly added though if we play
swanky i apologize because
all i do is die into ghost flips
will you check out this hot new release
mass effect legendary edition i've heard
that hot new release is very good
yo
they just released three games
it's all right
i've
heard cool things about mass effect
yeah here i'm checking out uh i'm not
entirely sold on
but
oh boy
uh
and yeah ben you're saying there's no
preview or there's no update or anything
like that they might just be offline
right now
they're not the they're like tweeting
out like
two hours ago they were like ah these
people are going live straight in the
game
um
which was their last tweet two hours ago
i'm gonna take it to the safest place on
the internet the student forums
let's see how they're going
oh boy
full of rational like-minded people oh
yes they're definitely having a civil
conversation about how it's the first
day for game in progress preview
[Laughter]
there you go man would you believe i'm
not right at all about that
but there are people talking about the
problem
okay
oh man
well that just goes to you know egg on
my face i should have checked that i
guess before they didn't they watching
that they're fixing it momentarily
okay
so they're they're on it they're on it
the developer they're working on it
they're on it now by momentarily is that
i'm assuming that's not going to go you
know
like a minute
or two
uh it would be nice if we if we found
the 20 year old mess or 20
minute year or 20 minute message and
just
had it already fixed it was already
fixed
oh great um
there are people already giving feedback
on the game
yeah dang
i'm betting someone pushes the feedback
that i deserve
uh i think i think now
uh
might just might just call it then might
this might just be a bust of a stream if
that's the case uh
that'd be a real bummer though
yeah it would be a real bummer but i
mean if the game's not working the
game's not working you know
dang
i'm gonna try
we'll try to play a solid first stream
for me guys
you did a great job
good luck charm
oh man
you can't even i assume if i try like
episode two like that would work
i tried that already oh you did yeah
well it says that that server game i bet
someone i bet they pushed an update to a
server
and the client version isn't ready so
they just don't match up right right
that makes sense
um
i mean gaming fire says uh chewing
sweethearts and watching movie on
netflix i mean
uh i'm not looking to get uh dmc8 you
know but uh yeah that's that's the new
hotness though that's what all the big
streamers are that's what all the cool
kids are doing i mean we oh yeah like
you know we could put some anime on here
and we could just watch some uh
deep rock galactic
games good
uh i've heard good things about that
game but i actually haven't checked that
out yeah i should i need to play that
you should
yeah it's very good
um
well
i think we're just gonna call it here
guys sorry for uh
wasting everyone's time i guess
i'm just saying i'd be down to wait like
10 minutes if we want to give a little
bit of time
hmm
how you're up to the feeling about just
hanging out with people for 10 minutes i
mean i'm happy to wait
a few minutes um
there's that part of me that's just like
oh god i got other stuff i could be
doing uh for work yeah um i do think
about that a lot but it's after work for
me so i'm i'm oh yeah you're you're good
yeah
yeah it's 5pm where i'm at so i'm done
oh lucky lucky for you dang yeah east
coast it's currently clocked out to my
time
i was gonna say should we we gotta we
gotta trade that out or something
bob jones says he's only been 12 you got
to waste that wait at least 15. you know
what all right well we'll give it a few
more minutes we'll just hang out here
um
and go far more harpy feathers on my
witcher play through
well
i thought about trying that game again
but then i realized i should just wait
for the graphical update
if it ever happens
yeah i mean they
they said they're working on it right
like it's gonna be sometime this year
it is rightful time for a remastered or
like a remake of because
mass effect 2 is about the same age as
witcher 2 i think
yeah
i'm bomb they never did that uh that
console version of witcher one that got
cancelled
yeah way back in the day um
i think you could
that game could play you could use it
yeah
i played witcher one yeah like a couple
years ago
and it was
actually i enjoyed the witcher one so
much that i did not like the witcher 2
because they like changed it so much i
actually in red i liked when it came out
i was like oh witcher 2 it's so it looks
so pretty and it's like you know they've
changed the combat in retrospect i think
it's actually the weakest of the three
games um i think the first game for his
like jank as it is has so much like
weird creativity
and like nuance to a lot of its
mechanics that makes it like really
really fun once you like get over that
hump
uh where like witcher 2 feels like they
really like toned everything down in a
way that i find less interesting
and then three feels like the
the right balance between the two
yeah i can see that i think i think i
like one so much because i was in like a
like an immersive sim pc game sort of
space when i played it
and it's just so like
it's so
pc game it is it's extremely pc game
like the menu is the most pc ass looking
like
just hot garbage like
looking menu like i love it and it's
it's tough
it's very tough um i remember doing the
final boss fight
five or six times and like spamming
health potion
i mean two feels pretty clunky like i i
was like no liking destiny up until this
so coming from a game that is
consistently updated to a game that's
like 12 years old now yeah it's uh
definitely jarring you're too skunky
especially like
playing three because i feel like they
really like cleaned up the combat um or
two they were like going for more of a
like uh
uh
i don't know like kind of not dark souls
either sort of like animation priority
kind of uh a little bit of like batman
arkham kind of energy to it it's like
assassin's creedy yeah yeah that kind of
thing but it just it didn't
something about it doesn't feel quite as
snappy as it should uh it's just like
the targeting system is just off yeah
exactly it's just like a little off
i am looking forward to three though
because uh apparently it's one of our
only uh 10 out of 10 rated games
oh yeah yeah well deserved 10. it's a
fantastic game
um that whole the whole game's amazing
all right
let me see if i should
pop back in and give another try
the monster hunter raising the piece i
haven't yet brandon but i want to i have
it
i checked out a little bit of it uh on
the
uh
for for preview um
it's good it's
monster hunter on pc i don't think i'm
gonna play it again because i've already
sunk
like a well over 150 hours into
uh that game on switch and if i can't
transfer my character over i'm not
all that interested in starting over
again
yeah
games without cross safe across play
whack yeah
yeah that's the one thing um
i like about ubisoft games is is they've
started to really like make that
universal where like if you have your
uplay account you can log in um
unfortunately i just don't like many
ubisoft games so i don't actually
have a reason to do it that often but
in theory i'm like that's cool like you
can like i mean he watches them like
called call of duty crosstalk dude he
does it too yeah borderlands cross play
now oh yeah yeah yeah um yeah let's get
back into that capcom's the next people
that need to get on that get on that
cosplay game
come on capcom
get together
spoiled by destiny absolutely destiny is
a great example
um it took a it took destiny a while to
do that though it did take destiny for a
long time i'm sure that they have to
i bet you the behind the scenes for
getting that to work was a nightmare oh
my god yeah
yeah
all right my loading is hung up
let me see if you actually load it
yeah i'm in the game we should try oh
you are yeah i might be no i'm not in
one i'm in a game with someone
okay
yeah if that's the case
ben let's join on you so i have another
person in here well here you uh but like
you quit out but let's
uh
yeah like have you be the party leader
okay
i'm i'm out and i'm
ready okay
i'm gonna be honest the whole time we've
been here i've literally just been
spamming start that's what i've been
doing
uh and it it finally let me in
hey they've at least
they've updated their that news feed has
been updated twice since we've been here
so
responding
okay i'm gonna join your game
stupid windows game
now below you're right capcom uh does
have cross-play uh when it comes to
street fighter that's a good point they
do have street fighter cross play um but
i i just need you know a monster hunter
i need that monster hunter cross play
ben can you invite me because it won't
let me join you
uh
i'm just gonna i'm gonna did you guys
really quick
i'm probably making you
visual high says what's everyone think
of anna cruises
i greet my music music
uh a cool lovely menu experience yeah
lovely menu experience the the selection
of five banners are quite nice i'm a big
fan of the green one
uh i like the spinny loading bar in the
bottom left-hand corner loading in to
know that my game hasn't frozen yeah
the uh i i appreciate how the the
background with like the you know
uh showing some of the game with like
the aliens moving very big left for dead
vibes
in a nice way that feels like a nice
little homage to that
uh actual game quality not sure yet
because we're still trying to get in
hopefully we'll get there
i'm a big fan of ver dot
25203-win dash prod uh just having that
there
keeps me safe on the bottom right hand
corner it lets you know where i'm at
i see three rooms labeled three two one
in my loading screen so i'd like to have
the decal on the walls to you know for
call outs if we need them
three
two
visual high says this was the fastest
uninstall i've had in a while sadly
that's a bummer i mean it's still day
one i'm i'm
uh
hopeful that you know like we'll fix it
we'll get it started uh and also this
game is like early access still this the
game's not even like out
so
i don't know games like this um
i tend to not judge too harshly uh until
the full it's fully released
yeah the proper time given the proper
time you know
also i didn't pay any money for this it
was on game pass
i didn't waste it
on a game pass download
what would you score the menu eight out
of ten yeah a solid eight out of ten um
[Laughter]
all right let's hit this button let's
see let's see this work let's see it
come together
oh hi hello there i don't know if you
might's picking up but my cat is
i think it's working
yeah
are we gentlemen
oh oh we lost someone oh it might be me
i think my menu's frozen
we did lose you but
but you can rejoin you can rejoin oh my
oh there's good teams
whoa
tanks i call
them from let me quit out and rejoin
stupid all right
we're in ladies and gentlemen smart
calling them brutes did y'all need to
download an update
no
i'm so happy that it came together
oh framy oh yeah
oh geez uh-oh don't let lance do
anything lance
don't do anything don't open the door
please stay there don't move don't
breathe
this gives me a chance to learn the
controls oh my god this frame rate oh
we're playing on uh xbox series x by the
way so i mean i'm this game should be
this sister should be able to run this
game
i can push them through the wall
that's cool so they're they're proper
weapons on the walls too okay uh i got
some sort of shotgun
oh some nice cal effects
oh i like your little hair buns
no thank you
okay
we're just going to review this one part
at a time yeah
now we're in the elevator this elevator
is pretty okay okay let's wait what do
we think of this b over here how would
you rate uh
ben ben hold on go back yeah yeah yeah
how would you rate your your contortion
there on on that consortium yeah yeah
yeah oh yep stop right there uh-huh okay
yeah perfect no no no wait stop don't
move yes oh nailed it yes oh okay
that is it i'm i'm practiced and what
i'm doing i'm a professional don't try
to replicate this i
just the thing you're on needs to be
sanitized oh no because you are so
inside of it
oh no
um
even lance is observing you yeah lance
is disturbed he looks like he wants to
kill you to be honest
hold on wait
thing lance
oh your back foot broken
it's better this way
[Laughter]
oh you can charge weapon
14.95
any luck phoenix
um let me see if i can join you
cool all right let's see this works
i keep pushing shift tab to like open up
the steam overlay
not on steam anymore
i'm gonna uh territory now i'm gonna
take my field of view out a little bit
this is a cool 100 a nice loading screen
i'm on an ultra wide so 90s just
it's nothing fancy i've had it for like
a long time
it's mostly i bought it for editing the
pistol looks like the gun from logan's
run oh oh it does
i've never actually seen logan's run
it's pretty good
for like a 70s sci-fi movie yeah
it's just one of those movies i always
hear about i'm like i should i probably
should watch that at some point yeah
oh here we go
what's the goal of this game to not die
and get to the end it's just like we're
dead with aliens okay i'm gonna go with
the smg i think
yeah the smg is pretty good you can also
get an upgrade for it that lets your
shots like automatically pick towards
things okay anything's wrong with this
i gotta say this game feels uh
not great
on
xbox so actually i was big worried about
was playing on my sensitivity needs to
go way up but but it all at least does
it feel swimmy to you like it feels
very swimmy in spots the frame rate is
just
dipping in places oh wow
oh i'm ripping over here uh there's
upgrades over here if anyone wants them
right here i messed up not going pc then
yeah i feel like this is definitely a pc
it's also definitely early access well
that too yes because my gun just spawned
how do you ping inside me
uh
i got my truck i do not know oh there's
a big boy up top
middle mouse
oh that's how i wave all right
yeah that guy looks like he's stumbled
out of a ball
i'm kind of okay with that
oh he is just he's got johnny playing
quality performance oh i didn't check
yeah maybe there's a uh
uh okay well turn hdr off because i'm
technically not using it um
there does not seem to be any sort of
whoa
turn g-sync off i'm getting some uh some
fun
jumpy connection stuff are you getting
fun server lag
that's what i'm getting
feels good turning the sync off might
have actually helped a little bit
i can believe that
ooh the
sync off is that what you did okay yeah
i say it helped but it
might not be actually that much the
machine gun makes a different noise as
you end
near the end of the clip which is oh
it's rubber banded yeah
and maybe it's all the people like
finally getting in because the thing
fixes
i can't choose whoa
teleported through like three walls
faster game of the year let's try and
pick up some cindy are we all sprinting
uh
you're just always sprinting
uh one of those games yeah
why go fast when you can always go fast
two speeds
it's got a level out eventually yeah i
mean
it's gotta said the captain of the
titanic
everything my guy said shots are real
smooth
we'll just hit another iceberg and level
it out
i'm calling my boss
oh there's so many
things
it's so bright
i keep rubber banding back into it yeah
when you want to run backward but the
game says no
it's so bright though
where is it
oh my god
it's
so fun disappeared
oh i can't i can't it's so bright
hold on i think i think i'm on him i'm
shooting him so many times oh
okay
my retinas
that's a that's a unique enemy oh
that i i think i'm here for her actually
i like that enemy design so far
oh what is this ability i'm doing my
left bumper oh that's your knockback
that's your melee
[Music]
no i think i think i actually ran out of
ammo
that's good
because you're gonna charge your weapon
up over here
oh
the director knew you're like ah
these lag fits they're too much
is this how i get the ray gun okay i
need to figure out what the ping is
that's not the pain am i waiting that's
a huge i'm gonna scan myself oh yeah ben
what was the ping for keyboard
uh
uh middle mouse middle mouse oh it is
middle mouse
okay that
there's got to be a ping here ping pong
click in left stick
yeah you got to make sure you're aimed
at something oh okay yeah it doesn't
ping the ground like apex i have to
address it
oh no it does never mind i'm a liar
charger here's a charger
[Music]
okay i think we found the charger here
as long as i can spam the charger here
this game's on
hey guys i'm out of ammo do you know
where charger is
i got beans
charger top off your weapons
all right
where are we going
i think we're going up this way
oh there's a bad boy over here yeah
cause i i'm i'm still pretty sure that
the lag stuff is probably because of the
oh the server stuff like everyone
getting back in oh absolutely
i mean i'm having a bla this game feels
pretty good yeah i actually kind of dig
how it is on the mountain keyboard
yeah i think my only issues is
like the i don't know the pc or the
actual piece of candy
like uh like the front it's very framing
on xbox it doesn't feel awkward yet
uh i don't know how the xbox has got
some some weird lag or weird
frame rates
okay well i'm taking some some good
damage here but that's say okay
this this i know it's not quite it but
the space design
feels like we're in like a
fallout vault
yeah yeah i mean uh phoenix your
character just straight up looks like a
uh
they belong in a vault
it's also not holding a gun i switch
guns and i'm lagging so he's just
bullets disappearing on my screen
when i pull the trigger
my pistol uh gets really big sometimes
oh
that's called a doctor about that
oh
my screen actually just did the same
thing i know exactly what you're talking
about
yeah eat it
oh no i've been gooped again uh oh you
freaking more huh you just i believe
this
thank you
weight wings says i like the concept i
like it too i mean you know it's it's
it's left 4 dead in space right and um
i don't know i was thinking about it i
don't know how you guys feel about it i
really liked back for blood last year
but i feel like it didn't really hold my
attention the way i was
hoping for if that makes any sense you
know like somebody played like so much
left for dead and i was like it's left
for dead three it's this is on paper
exactly what i want
but it's like
i don't know it's like it met my
expectations but it didn't
it didn't hold my attention yeah
i like i enjoyed playing it number two
no no i i did like it's not a bad game
by any means and then
it was also like super difficult
it is super difficult
they had to go and put in a whole other
difficulty just to kind of like
get something that's not too hard or too
easy
that back for blood feels like the kind
of game that like give it like a little
bit of time some tlc some more polish a
little bit more like new maps and i
think it could be
yeah it could be real real good
i don't know if you touched on it but
the characters were extremely annoying
oh and that was the other thing
yeah they were just okay they didn't
have that left for dead charm that i was
looking for you know
oh what am i shooting i don't know i
know coach
you know oh
oh there's another one of those flashy
guys
don't worry i'll get on with this laser
beam with the ray gun
okay that was kind of a bad spot to
throw that but that is like a weird time
bubble toby
oh
fire's back
i can't
okay i got it somehow
it was good everywhere yeah
i threw four of them
the group catches on fire
thanks
some some divinity two type nonsense
going on
oh no
i set everything on fire
you're right this is just first person
divinity too
i was literally about to even ask where
i charged it i got a bullets this is
nice oh my frame rate is
dying
it's because of all this luggage
it's too much to carry the the power of
the
laser jacks can't handle that yeah this
much luggage
oh it's like a third oh there's a
charger
every once every one charger here
[Laughter]
oh
i like it
oops
oh that laser's kind of sick though did
you laser me can is it
no
i didn't
i don't know
yeah
that sounds like an audio cue for a
horde yeah
that sounds bad
oh
big guy
gosh what is happening what
a couple of them were a little late
my game did not know how to process that
information
i can't see
oh he's right in front
back in the last room
yeah
i don't want to jinx it but i think the
bag might be oh hold up doing a health
scan
do you say that
oh
just what i needed
that's the way forward oh probably up
here yeah yeah yeah that's whatever you
what you guys are
i need health actually i have health i
should probably oh i have uh i have a
health scanner
this is for something there we go yeah
i'm i'm having i'm happy as the lag is
kind of subsided i'm kind of like
falling back into the left 4 dead guru
like
just shooting stuff i regret not picking
pc
it's ok i mean
it's play anywhere you could always you
know switch later yeah you could
download it right now
i meant for the stream
i feel like it's uh this is not the
optimal experience uh also
i mean at least this is good because we
can answer a broad range of questions
which is such as
maybe don't play it on console quite yet
yeah
it sounds rough in a lot of ways
yeah it's just it's just real rough
sensitivity just feels off like no
matter how much i adjusted sensitivity
feels off
a lot of frame pacing issues
finally there's a charge finally a
charger
everyone charges
we got a bumper i love it uh i like
these little loading screens
get the little like girl in the gum like
breakdown every time one comes up we got
this far congratulations everyone it
said radiation on my screen pretty hard
yeah there's healing
okay
open that door up thanks i'll try a
different weapon
oh you guys already in i'm still on the
loading screen
sweet speed console load time it's all
good
which xbox are you on uh xbox one x
oh okay
listen
i think the other
one yeah
so pretty because they're amazing naming
conventions you know making you guys
know exactly what i'm talking about
of course
it's only man
i know 3ds
i don't mean to uh
sound like a hashtag ad here but um
if you trade in an xbox one x it's the
same price as an xbox series s
wow
runs way better that's a pretty good
upgrade actually because i just did that
for my girlfriend
and it's a sweet 1440p machine
that's not bad at all
wait where can you play them uh at game
stop
you can trade in
uh and you just pay 20 bucks in shipping
if it's not at the store
got a lot of stock there it'll be great
perfect
highly recommend
ah
i
can't stop moving
i was really wondering
when the next charger would be
finally
there's a
charger here
i didn't even know that
what turned around
i don't know can you pick anything that
turns red i wasn't sure what it was
you know you hit me right
search the room
that's my favorite thing in video games
is sassy uh
you shot me
sounds
just being so nonchalant about the fact
that someone just shot you know you did
that right
[Music]
it's everywhere oh it is nasty
is anyone using the blaster i've been
sticking with the smg uh i'd switch to
the blaster to give it a try
it's not just a regular rifle
or no sorry i'm not the rifle do you
write the blasters the shotgun i do not
have the blaster
i'm still riding with this i'm not
really into this smg
yeah this is a rifle smg is pretty nice
i'll go back to the charger it's got
that i got that upgrade for it so my
shot's home
how'd you oh what
those matter converger things yeah yeah
it's that
it was like outside the very first room
and we were doing oh wow brother issues
okay yeah they're they're like
brand new machines that give you perks
i don't even remember what i chose
you know i'll pick up this
give that a try
or uh oh
oh fire three shot burst with your
pistol oh
well that's why that does that no no
turret i'm gonna take that
nice
we can hide in these bathrooms
there's like a one second delay between
when i shoot them and when they fall
down
[Music]
oh that guy flew oh oh
damn these are some nice quarters
so i really like that the the knockback
is not just a melee in this game but
it's that repulsor field
because sometimes it just causes the
ragdolls to fly really high
and that's really all i want oh big bad
guy need some help
oh that's a
flipping
it's to give me got it
there we go
not dead yet thanks for the hill hey
live again
oh i have a health boost i can give you
okay
oh no i gave it to myself
hey you want this too bad i was trying
to left for death but here we go
well this one's inside of here
he bust out
no
i hit him with the
blast
i was kind of hoping that he'd be able
to knock the door down
and i was able to hit his hands
guys
how did you do that
of course
oh
whole time
there's stairs back here game looks too
easy i think this is just whatever the
default difficulty was
uh i think we're too worried about
getting into a game so
worried about difficulty
yeah
but i'm sure they have other
difficulties too
hello
okay they're a lot oh nothing a lot of
oh there's a turret
all right
healing
whoa
across the room yeah i really did
let's keep moving
this is a creepy hall
careful i agree
i guarantee you could fall into that
fire pit
what the what what the heck
what
oh damn i don't know if the lag makes
that look more scary i don't like it
either way
oh my ammo wow
all right it's gross
that was terrifying
oh thank goodness
hey my charger
blue
all right there switch off the blaster
i'm not dang it that's just another
blaster
this game is saying makers is left so
there's a person oh i can pick up the
blaster
and some team fortress 2 people i think
that's a guy you can keep
no i want to try the blaster yo that
actually makes a lot of sense because of
the art style and the game time is here
yeah it's some of uh
left 4 dead and then i and team
fortune's like
a couple of people from riot
oh
i didn't i didn't even put the team
fortress
thing down with the aesthetic
oh sure
wait no i'm like oh yeah
oh i didn't even see this there should
be a service
[Music]
alert aliens
yeah just watching the canisters
[Laughter]
when you try to switch grenades your
grenades will also float there's a
little nade over here where you swap it
you see my incendiary just floating
around oh i didn't mean to do that
okay get ready get ready get ready
get ready guys ready i'm ready i'm ready
i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready
[Applause]
wait a minute
oh
okay
all the time hell yeah of course
[Music]
oh hello ragdoll physics
death from
[Music]
above guys
[Music]
no i got grabbed
grab me tom cruise
yeah crab like through a wall i don't
know if i could shoot that guy
oh yeah i got him
thank you
oh my god
get off me the door's open let's go get
it
well i've literally won health
i could try to heal you but i'll
probably stand up healing myself
you're good i mean you can also use this
feeling
healing i felt my death
oh no
man they don't even give you the like
left 4 dead like you're hanging can save
yourself just
nope nope i just walked i just walked
off the ledge because i thought that was
where you're supposed to go
there's another perk maker here
an arc rifle
or ammunition heck yeah pulse recycler
defensive gu
oh more
ammunition for sure
right before the upgrade machine oh uh i
just realized we're calling you back in
grabber yeah i did that
i only read the message afterwards that
it would call in
it's fine uh
it seems
pretty good so far
plasma rifle shots go through multiple
enemies
oh that's awesome
oh there's health up here
yeah i seem to find a plasma rifle
this does kind of feel like a bit of
like a safe
version of left 4 dead oh my goodness
i love
john luke with health confidently ran
and grabbed the health healing but i
didn't grab it
oh you didn't no no that wasn't me
on my screen you like leaned down and it
disappeared
i don't know what you're talking about
here there's another
health oh my goodness
oh he's right here oh kill him
got him
oh yeah yeah
that
i like how
just messed up that enemy yes
hello i got you thank you yeah
i'm thinking there's
i can get my weapons charged up
ah nice assistant i think i might have
shot that no no that's what i wanted
did good
we're doing it
i don't know what is happening anymore
wherever i go
flying all over the place i gotcha
okay
this is pretty cool although i did just
run out of mls
we have to be coming up on an elevator
just right there
did that thing just laugh i think so i
don't like it
oh everyone in here
close that door
i want my smg back
nailed it perfect didn't
not a single problem boom boom
rifles we got blasters
smg's
seems to be it
oh that perk that gives you extra
primary ammo doubles it
oh no i may have crashed
oh no
we can we
and now
nothing
is working
there's a charger
oh good oh there it goes
okay reloading
there's a charger
blue
a gion
[Music]
i like the very left or dead thing being
able to just call it there's a health
display oh
can this thing give me
oh just healing
nasty
you upgrade gun so it seems like you get
perks that make the guns better yeah
like i have one that makes the shots
from the
machine gun automatically track nearby
targets oh
oh
i don't know if you can get a super
extended outcry i'd like them
just said i couldn't join the game
because the game is full
that's a lie oh
so you're you're still in technically
but now you
think it's a bomb
again so try joining now
security is on the 11th floor
it was weird because john luke's screen
still said hunt 270 and i think when i
joined the game realized i wasn't there
anymore right
okay i'm in
i do love a lot of the environments in
this game
looks great
yeah
oh this glass breaks really cool
spawner
yeah yeah
oh god whoa oh no
right boy
got him
oh i think i found it
oh gosh the leg has been real oh wow
the thing we are too good for too long
yeah these guys are about to beat the
game stop them
by any means possible
that'd be crazy if a game mechanic was
lag
uh there's a real eternal darkness type
type stuff
yeah god i love that game big scene
those
this music playing in this uh
like mall is
very relaxing yeah it's very um
there's a british band
that plays like that and they're in
walls and grommet and i can't think of
their name but
that's what it sounds like
here
i wonder how much of this stuff is
randomized
to like
what type of layout things can move
around
so i think that's a thing that
oh no way this whole area is randomized
i don't think the area is but like
debris and stuff you have to jump around
oh is the debris you think
yeah because i there's some stuff that
seems different from the one game that i
joined for like
five seconds
but it's not interesting interesting
too big oh laser
rifle definitely a game i'd like to play
at being a knight
that's fair
man this music is good
it's a it's set in the mood
look at that laser beam though
yeah that just feels good
ow
shotgun over there
oh
well that's weird
what happened like the
windows
early access everyone
it's a real thing
i can open up the gate for you
still better than cyberpunk
[Laughter]
quite a bar to beat there
oh
i like to hang out at like a space
nice deco bar
there's a button in there i want it
shoot the button
in the bathroom
oh
weird let me get over there
so i think the the button there's a
button in here too
like they they come from from going
around do you so
it's me catch me running ahead
uh this sounds like a bad sound
why i hear boss music again
uh there's a perks up here
oh wow
uh corgi says what do you think of the
game
i think for an early access title shows
a lot of potential
i hope they can uh make something
special i
i can see it too
i think right now did i get booted
dealing with some uh some silly server
stuff but
oh i think you did
when it's when it's working though i'm
having a good time a lot of silly
service stuff and then
the game's kind of a little rough uh on
the xbox i don't play on the xbox if you
want to give it a try
yes oh man
all of my weapons were in the center of
my screen for a good bit
that's the that's the flipping
doom mode
oh god
also we lost phoenix
yeah
i watched this character go through an
existential crisis
uh hopefully
you'll just join back in yeah you should
be able to
yeah i think so
the infinite threshold stable aquatic
nutrients
all right i gotta pick my shoulder
let's see
[Music]
does anyone else see
alien legs through this floor
uh
let me come check it out
yes
there's one over here too just having a
good time
oh there we go
how long is an episode uh they feel like
they last i have this same length as
like a left head
episode
uh can you shoot me tonight
oh yeah i'll shoot you one
i almost joined you by accident
oh
no no no bad
even difficulty wise like
we're not like getting overwhelmed and
we're not like having an easy time
kind of nice to just
well then we activate the lift the alien
you know what i'll uh scanning
[Music]
i'm going to use this on me
oops
there we go
there's uh some goo grenades over here
if anyone wants them
where's the upgrade station
and go back and grab something
uh yeah i was back where you dq'd
disconnect
an aquarium or something
i don't remember exactly what
it was in one of these little side rooms
yeah
i think we have a co-op button to do
here though
we do
oh i found it
yeah it says i already got a perk so
i guess i can't upgrade again oh maybe
your a i
did it
okay
right hit this button
yeah
three two one
go you ready
wow
oh the giant lamps are moving
oh here hmm
i'm just gonna sit in this corner
good
you're good did the lag save you the lag
saved to me
someone got good i got good i'm in a bad
way
yeah i am
i don't know what's happening
i thought i threw a grenade but i guess
i was a big guy
i just saw someone's teeth for a second
[Laughter]
like only for a split second and then
they disappeared
doctor i'm telling you i saw someone's
teeth
they'll never believe me
just give me the medication
i have an extra guy down there that's
happening i'm just
firing
i just watched someone fall
they'll never ban back up
help me
i'm trying i'm trying i'm trying
and i was trying
oh no oh it's all falling apart
like three stories down i wouldn't come
and get me
how did that even happen
i don't know
oh
i think the herd is thinning
i don't know if i'm actually out of
bullets or my bullets are just lagging
and not loading is not saying how many
bullets i have
oh
what what what what where am i what
i fell somehow oh you go in the elevator
and then like blast you upwards oh bye
guys i like when the elevator and then
it spawned me like on the left of the
elevator i went inside and then it
dropped me down
oh no
okay
wait am i up or down oh i'm down all
right i'm with phoenix we made it
i can i kill myself
i think we just gotta wait
it's gonna take forever yeah
and that flasher's running around
looking like an idiot from down the hall
okay we got to the safe room so we'll
get you guys back well i'm 11 health so
hope i can make it into the safe room
i hope you guys get rubber banded all
the way back here
hoping the great rubber band takes me
with yes oh praise him
he who is stretching
guess what
charger here oh okay
are we good it is worth reminding
everyone who's watching the scissors
yes
oh press h to respond
so do we need to wait for you guys to
respond then because it's not
we're in the safe room but nothing's
happening
it might be because
they're you're still alive yeah i'm
still alive i'm not dead yet
i'm almost dead
i hear the down but not out
[Music]
what did i miss
oh ben's back huh he comes back and he's
like what did i miss
i'm so close to death take me
there we
go
not a problem at all just
nailed it the whole way through
if you forget your friends just have
them die and then they'll respond with
you yeah
i do like that when you do have someone
who's like all the way out you can just
spawn them in on you
i like that you can yeah you can instead
of like the left 4 dead closets you can
spawn them on you but it calls a horde
i think that's a good trade-off you know
there's a charger
i've got a
radiation pump
yeah me too
i know what it means i don't like it hmm
i have a
there's like an x over my
profile like my character's icon i don't
know why
are you dead
it still thinks you're dead maybe
i never died though
oh also maybe you've never lived see
instead of seeing
uh
phoenix i see myself again
oh
like on the
what is going on
uh
you know earlier
we're just gonna keep going with it it's
fine you're getting
i should probably use a different gun
but this smg is just doing me very oh
it's so good
yeah we're outside but we're inside
oh look at the ceiling that's so cool
i like lcds that are failing
this reminds me of a zone
in
final fantasy 14
you mean the epic
free to play mmo
yeah
i guess it's not free to play it's free
this trial forever please don't care
about it because you can't log in still
that's insane to me you just still can't
play that game
why can't you log in
oh because there's so many people trying
to oh oh
i played a ton over the summer
and all my friends got mad at me because
i kept just doing jobs instead of
leveling up
that's fair and they told me i played
mmo's wrong
which was the wrong way to play that
third they're wrong
that's what i said i definitely spent a
weekend in the game just uh cooking
and i had a great time so you know what
yeah it's it's whole long thing you know
it's fun
right
and i never paid any money for like the
70 hours i put into that game it's true
it's a whole game expansion stasis
grenade
you're a health booster
a piece of candy like a little
you got me with that one
what i stole this radiation on my screen
big scene me too i have no idea what
that's about but it's not going up or
down
that's oh we got a perk over here
all right that's not dc this time i
still don't see phoenix's health bar i
just see my own twice
i think the console version might be a
lot more rough
seems like it
special weapons come with more
ammunition
i like that you just unleash a powerful
blast
uh we've got a lot of boys coming
towards us
oh
that's my power blast looking
gonna kill anything
please this is a family stream
if i kill things with headshots they
explode now
oh what
huh
for critical hits i assume a headshot is
a critic
yeah
i got grabbered behind you
coming back oh
thanks i think i may have shot you a
bunch
yeah i definitely need to heal after
that
the like jump enemies do when you kill
them is very good
yeah
it's because they're crouched and then
they go rigid and they like fly into the
air
excuse me
shooting a barrel is fun
watching enemies fly off into the sunset
is funny
i'm into that
hello please die
oh now we got spooky sounds too
i prefer spooky sounds one
ah
a classic
it's always in my car
there's something squishing around back
here yeah it's really gross
it's a gooper
super watch
yeah blaster
just waiting for the connection to catch
up you know yeah
right now
i just see a bunch more aliens spawning
in
and everyone running into walls
at least my health isn't moving i'm
teleporting too fast for the zombies
actually
it's a good point
now on their end it looks like a like a
like a dragon ball fight
yeah it's like just flying around yeah
this guy's getting totally beamed any
minute now any minute now it's gonna be
game come on come on game
it's like it's like five o'clock
somewhere now people it's like right
every one of the zombies is connecting
to the game
[Laughter]
they're all trying to log into the
server
yeah they're all people at the stage i
just watched a zombie sprint off the map
i've got one who's half inside of a wall
of course i'm going this way i'm just
getting away from it
yeah what are we doing where do we need
to go i'm going into the garden down
this way yeah oh down okay
i'm gonna pick up this shotgun
oh i found another matter compiler
compiler oh yeah give give me more cool
perks
part protocol
wow if you stand in goo it heals you
oh i had that one earlier but i didn't
take it
doing a health scan
[Music]
don't do that
no i'll get that the healing goo
i got a health booster
my fourth cove is shot
look at the goo one as well
oh so you got defensive boo i got
healing goo
we get all the good
oh no gooey no these are awesome that's
what makes the music
look at him yeah the lag just
stasis grenade go instantly more
terrifying
i don't think it did anything
yeah i threw a grenade too and it oh i
just went third yeah my grenade just
completely disappeared
do you say you go third person yeah i
just went third person
that's a feature okay i can't shoot
anymore
oh my god
are they gone we're going my grenade
just went off
i don't even know what happened to my
good grenade
the server stuff is sorted out for this
game i'm gonna be too good at it it's a
bright boy yeah we're we're gonna have
like you know
perfected it so so much
well playing underwater the whole time
has made it strong yeah you take the
training weights off right it's like a
hyperbolic chamber yeah it's rock lee
taking off the ankle weights
oh my god there's another one
it's so bright
it's the worst enemy ever
i'm the best depending on you know how
you feel about it
i'm about to play this in like a dark
room oh
it's 3am you've seen your like third
flasher
you just don't want it anymore
a charger
i'm pretty sure we're on pace for the
speed run yeah i'm feeling it
this is definitely world record
something okay just give me a do i
normally have a thousand ammo in this
thing
uh if you got the perk for emily oh i do
have the perk for ammo you're right
man that's crazy it is it just doubles
it yeah it's wild
that's too much
give you early access now it didn't this
is game pass
yeah it's on game pass
on game pass for everyone to watch
log on and
get the servers all riled up i picked i
had to oh there's yeah
is this the right way i have no idea i
was following you
we're just exploring
there's a laser rifle here if anyone oh
now it's a turret
now it's always alive
in here weapon here
i'll i'll take the laser rifle
you take the laser rifle
do you know where we're going i have no
idea
we'll find it out
i think oh i think over here
by me oh yeah going up would be what
where did you go oh i went up these
stairs over here
but it keeps rubber banding me to the
bottom
it's a jojo reference if i ever saw it
why am i walking is anyone's uh left
shift ability
knockback not filled up it's half
half yeah halfway for me yes
yeah
so we jump over this
i guess i hit the button and it seemed
to work though so that might just be a
ui
yeah
ooh these flowers are nice what's gonna
say i like the flowers everyone get
ready this is gonna get bad
everyone get ready this is gonna get bad
yeah i'm about to fart it's gonna get
really bad
i just watched it dude ascend to heaven
i just watched it i must go my people
meet me
oh my god i just realized everything
that runs through here moves the flowers
oh no that's gonna
oh no this
oh now
i'm just going to walk through the
flowers i'm not going to stand still
oh it's dry
the gazebo is on fire
oh there's a door over there
wait did i actually pick that up no
hey safe room
i escaped
well like i said it's it's still early
access so there's tons of
oh yeah this is like day one early
access the game's not even finished yet
wait how'd you get in the room
what there's nothing behind me what are
you talking about oh hey there's someone
you can charge our weapons
out here
can you guys open the door for me please
it's very much open
it half it's not up to us yeah you can
still make it in
uh
no it's like half open
here i'll do like a jump that's how it
was for me it says i'm in i'm in now i
told you
i closed it oh you guys are everywhere
it's all the people walking in oh thank
god
it's so it's so much it's too much to
take
this is that that james webb they just
sent out that it's beaming to us this
game right now
get out of the andromeda galaxy yeah
okay so my my shift repulsor blast is is
working again yeah i'm not irradiated
anymore
this is going to be the normal one this
i can see i can see phoenix's uh
health now so that's good
i'm still in the game that's a good sign
everything's coming together
things coming up gamespot yeah yeah yeah
okay
really is a safe room
i'm gonna hit the button
was a lot of him
excuse me
up the lift to the bridge
that was fun
oh
oh heck yeah more perks
what
oh i see someone's tongue and teeth
there it is
increased maximum health oh heck yeah
yeah health a health extender
it's okay i've got
this arc cannon
i can't see but i'm holding down the
button
thanks
oh grammar
[Applause]
just yelled in this other room
[Music]
i'll break you out of your goo prison
hold on hold on everyone gather up on my
group
it heals i think
oh yeah i don't think it heals me it
just
it heals when you throw it
yeah yeah
i have that perk too
oh yeah that works heck yeah
everyone's healthy thanks to the goo oh
thanks goo i'll praise the goo
mighty goo overlords
oh do we hit these buttons at the same
time
all right so
like a super nice button okay this is
definitely the last area
oh
that's another matter compiler
there's a charger
oh
get ammo when after i
feel something i've marked oh move up
full speed on alien goo hell yeah
they want to help me with these buttons
oh yeah yeah yeah okay three two one
push
everyone ready
oh
it's straight up is just like yep this
is it we're going
oh this this elevator does not work oh
no it does
oh there are a lot of health kits up
here
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you this shift design is real cool
yeah i want to see it from the outside
if the elevator works when it wants to
yeah
it's really
very moody
oh there's some guys stuck in the floor
up here
they're
they're on their own journey
[Music]
nope
oh i'm shooting
thank you gotcha
got him
yep there's some health over here if
anyone needs it
oh my god i got my turn on dude
i don't get healed by the goose
ow oh
hang on gonna run this game
i like the music in this game too so far
yeah music solid
music solid i like the art direction
i like the alien design
yeah the choice to make you lag all the
time is a weird one but that's a weird
one yeah definitely because you're
playing on a high difficulty
it's an artificial difficulty it's hard
for me to judge the mechanics when just
my general experience has been uh very
framing and laggy overall scanner here
i'm glad i don't have the frame stuff
where the heck can i teleport to yeah i
think that the frame stuff might be
yeah that's a that's a console exclusive
console species
like the the the moments where like the
lag kind of catches up and everything
it feels good shooting stuff
i mean i'm into it
so what i'm doing now is i'm kind of
just like cueing up my uh my blast and
all my shots it's like oh yeah i think
there'll be a zombie here eventually
right
i'm so goofed right now i got you
teamwork
oh i got grouped again
that was a lagoon
oh he's like stuck in the walls
we got him
there's another one
i am brutal
oh right boy oh no
i got him
shooting him
well in my world i'm shooting him
he's dead
heck yeah
still up
oh i got an ammo refill somewhere along
the way
oh
healing
no
oh i down
i'm trying to get you
come on let's get you up
oh god
gosh
i think i got it
nice
and i think
i think like
time to kill on things feels okay
i got grabbed in like a corner
maybe it's hard to tell
i think
where are you oh i see
thanks
let's get you up
down again
this music is going wild what's gonna
say
yep
[Music]
there's another big guy
no he died
[Music]
are we supposed to go in that service
corridor over there oh yeah are we
supposed to be like doing it i thought
we were just like i thought we were just
gonna think about the health bar over
here are we defending this or
oh i killed the no that's uh that's my
turret yeah
oh i think over by me is where we're
supposed to go
okay yeah we're sounding crazy
no i am crazy you're not supposed to
yeah no that's just where enemies come
out of yeah
i think we're just supposed to be
defending oh there's grenades over here
[Music]
there we go
oh there we go yeah i think you got him
dude
oh yeah the center console the thing
popped up pick up memory device
i got the data
cool what do we do with that i don't
know but it's floating and i'm in third
person
we get it out of here the aliens they
wanted
my game went black oh hey we did it
apparently
uh we hello
okay then
success
yeah
yeah that was a little abrupt
i had no current quest that's the
saddest part
no current quest dang wait what how does
that work what
i think i bet they're like or something
yeah oh okay
well
i think that's what we're gonna call it
on this one uh yeah that was the
anachrosis uh i gotta be honest i don't
really
know how i feel about the game itself
because i feel like i
didn't really get a chance to experience
it the way
uh
i should
to form my opinion on it
yeah we hope that they get the server
stuff sorted out at least so we can
start yeah
playing it playing it
yeah what would you guys think
how'd you guys feel about it
i mean i i would love to give it another
chance but if it's gonna play like that
again
i'm i'm not there for sure yeah i'm not
i'm not i'm waiting until the servers
are a little bit better um
and i i would i definitely am
downloading it on pc because yeah it is
it's a bit rough on on xbox that's my
big takeaways don't play it on xbox for
now because
it doesn't seem optimized compared to
the pc version
um anyway that's going to do it for uh
our live stream of the anna cruz thank
you everyone who uh came in hung out um
and yeah uh we're gonna be
doing more fun live streams uh in the
coming weeks is the big games coming out
there's a lot of games coming out
actually real seriously
witch queen
witch queen which one
[Laughter]
nice
yeah which queen will be cool uh pokemon
pokemon i'm curious about that persona 4
arena ultimax in in march yes that'll be
a me and ben one for sure stalker in
december
yeah yeah some cool games coming out
this year we'll be
hopefully doing plenty of live streams
around those so yeah uh thanks for
watching everybody and we will catch you
all next time
bye bye
[Music]
you